150 b by the cal police one advisor
trying to breach and get to the capitol
while this building was under attack on
january the 6th what was donald trump
doing
the question at the heart of this
committee's investigation
now on prime time television this
hearing laid out what was happening
inside the white house president trump
did not fail to act during the 187
minutes between leaving the ellipse and
telling the mob to go home
he chose not to act
this committee revealed new evidence of
trump's inaction as he watched the riot
unfold on television from the west wing
at 2 13 protesters started kicking in
the windows of the capitol building
shortly after we see the vice president
mike pence being evacuated to safety by
the secret service
their radio recordings reveal a sense of
panic
if we lose
any more time we may have we may lose
the ability to
leave so if we're going to leave we need
to do it now one white house security
official described anonymously how at
this point staffers were beginning to
fear for their lives
a lot of very personal calls um over the
radio but there were calls to um say
goodbye to family
the mob's anger was directed at the vice
president but donald trump does not call
on them to stop
instead he tweets mike pence didn't have
the courage to do what should be done
then deputy press secretary sarah
matthews gave unparalleled insight into
the president's reluctance to call off
the mob
the president did not want to include
any sort of mention of peace in that
tweet
and it wasn't until ivanka trump
suggested the phrase stay peaceful that
he finally agreed to include it
to me
his refusal to act and call off the mob
that day and his refusal to condemn the
violence
was indefensible
a day later the agonizing and denial
continued the hearing shown outtakes of
donald trump's video message from
january the 7th
whenever you're ready
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the elections are but
i just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
dramatic testimony of a desperate
president on one of the most
extraordinary days in american history
sally lockwood sky news washington